I can't make bail it looks like we're
back back in round the murder
Oh what has happened since then um
really nothing it's been like six hours
outside by this last anyway let's just
get right into it let's just get right
into it
Wow
okay we're cleaning up the bag now
creaking loud huh nice there's an easier
way to do this I wish it was just like
Auto pick up I think it looks to it I
don't know see really see what the point
is I'm having to press like X every
single time but yeah and I like I'm not
the game designer like you know like
there's a lot of cameras out there wanna
travel no I will not travel okay
objective thank you
clean up the Burke me see what this
mission is though um
you found clutch apply but he still need
something to plug it in okay that'll do
once sir hammerlock who currently
resides in town of liars Berg and I get
that uh clap your ones you head there
now okay
any more on that here and when I got
shot I don't say anyone
well what's over here that I can't go in
there that's fine
dad it made the gun there well my guy is
like so Jack I don't like how is there
any way to like auto pick up dude like
holy crap and we say Hopkins game
playing come on dude Annie Auto pegging
what is the point of pressing X it's
like name of the night Kurt okay good
Jay I don't get money I could pick up I
don't see what like why would why would
I not want to pick up ammo is what I'm
saying you know someone trying to fight
me or something
okay I guess it's people over there but
there's Ludo right here so big you're
gonna have to hold on I'll bet you know
what is this of course come on come on
takes so long for it to open I just want
to forget to take the stuff
come on brown
you like that bad back wait was that it
I was like really easy no yeah no yeah
oh man I really hurt my hand on that one
wait why am i starting from all the
river here I went through all this
already what that help so that means
there's gonna be like a gigantic battle
in a second wait it's a guy went through
this but it's not even like it did it's
saved because I have like my my shotty
which is now oh my hand is a bleeding
why am I keep doing that
okay yes a we kill his people here yeah
we got to go up there again not even
bother with selfish stuff gang up here
that's weird I guess like it saves your
progress but it throws you at did my
spot kids right here I like this day
whoa he's freaking going for it
you like that bearing of crap
LS there a bang cap chap you can open
this up what defend claptrap no crap you
like that better
oh man a little explosion there ow
they're shooting me how is it yep what
is object everybody
and this gun sucks
well okay I got a lot of good parts dude
I need like better guns or something
okay okay right endless ah okay thank
you
whoa
at your service oh my god that really
hurt let's show it all this stuff is am
I supposed to be exploring this game or
what wait for a pair okay okay
get-get-get wait for power
what is the purpose this okay
whoa yeah do I need this
1:20 Sabbath kind of expensive huh
what's wrong with my stuff I have a
sniper rifle
I'm
[Music]
where they go well whoo
otherwise making weight hello sir
all right we did it thanks for watching
y'all thank you